i remember just how young we were just
how excited we were
one two three
we're on my bus pass i swear my bus
[Music]
rachel and rosario were just i can't
explain you the
relationship we had we love each other
[Music]
i wish we wore the cat ears
and the my hair the cat ears
and the tail more and we're always
tripping over each other's tails
stepping on them
i hope that you've got you played the
hell out of those drums tara oh wait
guys let's show them our hands
okay this is blowing my mind right now
i could cry watching this we had so much
fun
it's an eg it's an e.t it's an
e.t exclusive
[Music]
congratulations 20 years really like
it put a stamp on you know in movie
history
in a lot of ways hotter than you've ever
seen
everywhere cause it's a cult classic
like how does that make you feel i was
so excited to be
even asked to be a part of this and
rachel
welcome i remember i had just turned 21
filming in montreal and then i started
like four days later
in vancouver with these lovely ladies
and i was such a huge fan of theirs like
we couldn't go anywhere without people
like
jumping all over them and freaking out i
was like
big old macy gray behind them like my
curly hair like
ladies how can i protect you how can i
help you and he's like
awesome amazing you know i'd only kind
of been starting my career but to be
around all these women and to have this
community and this love and to be
telling this story that was so pro-women
and like just powerful this is it
pussycats
unplugged let's hear it tara what about
you when you think 20 years
how does that sit with your brain well i
know we're older now
rachel and rosario were just i can't
explain you that the
relationship we had it was just so much
fun it really was you played the hell
out of those drums tara
you totally had your hands from your
feet that was not easy you had
rosario and i think we could have faked
our instruments a little bit but if you
play the drums wrong it's so much more
obvious
when you were spot on can i tell you
guys something amazing before i forget
you just saw a clip that universal put
out about the anniversary and things and
there's this moment where
du jour sings into the microphone and
they sing
the entertainment tonight theme song
[Music]
you guys are talking about like you know
the the stuff the clips that they put
out so you know the et vault
is undefeated so we want to take you
back because we were
on the set of this film oh my god you
guys
so i want to take you back i'm scared
rachel rosario what are you doing
look how cute you guys come on in
we want to show you our house this is
where we live this is jesse
i want this so we want you to come on
and hang out with us reading some cake
and brownies
petting the cats i'm allergic to them
this is blowing my mind right now
my drums are a little messed up right
now i could cry watching this
this is my favorite movie i ever filmed
in my life i feel like i could have
tried a little harder to deliver for you
guys
he was the best juicy i mean like i
didn't offer
anything ever rosario could never been
replaced
rachel could never be replaced i
couldn't have we had such
magical energy we had so much fun like
yeah he was incredible
like it wasn't just a movie that we made
it was a a
an alliance of
not uh did we work together as soon as
we were off work
we went out it was amazing tara
no do town it was the buffalo wings wait
wait wait wait talk about the buffalo
wings i need you so
rosario when you look back at the girls
in that video 12
years ago on that set what do you think
about those girls
these are the legs that i dream of
having one day i mean we were such
babies we had no idea
you know what it could be later in those
moments like it's so weird thinking
about how much life
has happened now or you know it's 20
years later i mean it's it's really we
it's twice our age it just feels like a
whole other world has happened it feels
like a million years ago
i'd never met paparazzi until we're
doing the premiere for this
so i mean for me it feels like the very
very beginning of the industry like it
so much has happened since but in that
little moment it was my first
time working with big movie stars and
like this huge big production
and the costumes and everything and and
it was just
like i just felt like such an honor
what's a memorable moment
from from shooting that fans would get a
kick out of that like we didn't know
i always say this and the girls are
gonna know this too but it was so
cold in vancouver and we had these tiny
littlest outfits you've ever seen
especially tara
they'd be like and here's the scraps
that are left off of these yeah
yeah it's making another foot for dinner
one is in the movie and one is with us
without the movie when we get on that so
freezing scene and then we saw all of
our three uggs next to each other
it was incredible like i'll never forget
that ever like it was incredible
and then there was another scene that i
did with the girls
and uh we just got signed with a record
label
and we were in the bathroom they're like
oh my god
it was such a fun scene to do with them
everything i did with them like to me
we've all moved on and done money like a
lot of movies but
that was the most special movie i've
ever done it did feel really magical i
still
can't believe it every single scene felt
like a gift you know what i mean i
still don't know why they paid me for
that that was just
i don't know the whole thing felt
incredible there was
not a bad apple in the bunch like
usually there's one people who
person who you're like maybe not him but
like just everyone was incredible you
know
y'all had crazy guest stars i mean you
talked about donald faison
you had eugene levy parker posey alan
[ __ ]
seth green when you look back then and
you see all these
crazy cameos of like big superstars
forever too soon sorry
we love you carson you know i always
thought you were kind of hot
too bad i left him
off just because i was being respectful
i'm not afraid
i was not afraid of anything right i was
being respectful
never thank you for that did it not
click though
we had a lot of crazy good cameos here i
was gonna say i think that's part of one
of the things is that we definitely had
these really
very clear scenes and we got to do a lot
of fun rehearsal and all that kind of
stuff but so much of it
was just these moments of kind of just
capturing us being together
that were an unscripted there's like so
many beats in this room
you know even if it was just because
we're doing the music video or lip
syncing along or
whatever we're jamming we're you know
practicing you know we're kind of just
doing these
montage shots
[Music]
a big chunk of filming on this was us
just being together and vibing together
and then just capturing it and then
creating
these moments with the songs kind of
playing and i
it was such an unusual experience
because it really was about
our connection to each other our vibe
like
our solidarity and like you can't you
see it moment to moment when we have our
bus pass moments or whatever it is it
feels so authentic because we
really were this like family and like
you said about the supporting cast i
mean we got to kind of
be the anchors but what gives the movie
so much of its flavor like i'm going to
say 70
of it is the incredible supporting cast
that we had i still can't believe people
signed up to do
that movie i mean i can't because the
writing was so exceptional and i feel
like i just want to shout out
our directors for like just writing the
most incredible script ever like their
writing is truly the star of the movie
like devin harry
thank you i'm so glad that this movie is
getting the redemption to her that it is
oh
all the shadows okay can i blow your
all's mind of just a little bit more
aaliyah beyonce lisa left eye lopez
all auditioned to be in this movie and
like
i didn't even know that did you guys
know that what
you didn't know that no did you know
that
right there no rosario rachel knew that
how in the world did i get to be a part
of this
this is rachel you're a rock star so
you're fine they were like well give
someone a break
they're like these these girls are just
huge superstars we're like we'll try the
unknown girl
you had all that i remember credibility
from kids people were like oh my
goodness
she wants to like you know be in this on
the surface
kind of corny pop culture movie like
yeah yeah get her
please i mean only because it's devin
harry because anybody else would have
been like don't have her don't
no but they i think you were their
favorite to be honest yeah
there you go rosario that's a little
nugget for you to take
[Music]
can we talk about the fashion in this
film because
it was fabulous that early 2000s fashion
was fabulous
your favorite wardrobe piece that you
actually thought damn i look pretty fly
in this
i'm going to be honest with you my
favorite piece
i wore was like these like like bell
bottoms and this like little
top i had it i wanted to go to mtv movie
awards
they let me go and i wore the same
outfit that was so cool
okay rachel what about you go go for it
oh man it's hard to really look back on
the fashion and think that i really
should have been wearing any of that in
life
i thought for the film it was utterly
spectacular
lisa evans our costume designer who's
gone on to do a million huge movies just
knocked it out of the park for us
i kind of loved the uh like the sort of
ripped up sid vicious shirt that they
had me in
but the looks overall i i don't know
what to say
i just i think i i think every power
that is that my eyebrows grew back
that's all i know
about the fashion at that time which do
you prefer laney
boggs unibrow josie
or brook shields call it whatever you
want
[Music]
all yeah our music video outfits just i
thought for this the coolest pretend to
be nice
you guys killed it like there's no one
else that could
ever play these parts besides rachel
rosario
so what about the piece that you love
the least i didn't have an outfit
that i didn't like it would be more that
i wish we wore
the cat ears and the my hair
the cat ears and the tail more
at least we're not wearing stupid bunny
ears
they're not funny they're leopard and
they're not stupid they're special
we're special we used to call yeah
no we were like maybe just one or the
other and riverdale or like dc comics
had a mandate about wearing the ears and
the tails for at least a certain
percentage of the movie
and i remember personally being like do
you really need it for this one
i'm going to take these off i i was not
as pro tails and we were always tripping
over each other's tails stepping on them
yes you did i love my tail i was like
about my
[Music]
got all three of you all sung background
vocals right
yeah that was like that was exciting it
felt good that we had a little think on
it we put a little sink on it
and the the soundtrack went certified
gold right so you get royalty checks
no
rosario literally had to try so hard
because she had
no idea how to pay the base and rachel
had
no idea how to play the guitar and trust
me i had
no idea how to play the drums so in the
beginning of our
uh our shoot like before we had to get
lessons and whatever
and then i was talking i can't do it i
can't separate my hands to my feet
i was awful i'm like i'm gonna get
maybe they're gonna let me do the movie
these
these girls started rocking it out i'm
like oh my god they're so ahead of me i
can't even
i can't even do my hands and my feet and
then
do you think if you picked up if you
picked up a set of drums today could you
still rock out
i could definitely i know my hands and
my feet now like but you know what i do
the best bongos like i can be like
what about rachel what about you guys do
you think you can still maybe pick up
your
instrument guitar or anything and do a
little something
i think we could what i think is funny
though is like even in that moment
though where we were practicing so much
like there's that beat at the very end
like i always look at the moments when
we're
playing on screen if you keep it and
there's definitely times where i was
like i knew i saw the camera coming by
and i was like i'm gonna
do you were awesome but there's the beat
when at the very end and you two are
kissing and
i come up with the bass and it's you
hear the bass playing in the background
like
the holding music well i'm like you
gotta get back to the concert
and my hands are not doing anything that
they're supposed to be doing
it's one of my favorite things to do is
like watch movies and go like when it
doesn't connect
i'm like what i i mean i came over i had
a line i was like where was my head i i
clearly couldn't
speak and do
i think that was one of the best things
that like rachel
rosario and myself got to do is like
learn these i mean if we never did just
in the postcards trust me i would have
never learned the jobs
she probably would never win the guitar
and and you know we'll probably
would never learn at the base but we got
good at it
i mean that last concert we had when the
stage went up and
all the extras i mean i honestly feel
like i was a rock star
it was really fun that's not proper i
mean there was
tens of thousands of people there or
something there was it was just full-on
you you all had kind of touched on the
message of this film and kind of the
girl power of it so
i want to rewind yet again here comes
the et vault again
the story is really strong i mean it
really stresses individuality
and and strength and love and support
from friends
how strong do you think that message
still stands today i mean i see the
sisterhood here
that was so beautifully sad rosario
thank you for
taking if you're a rock star okay dude
yeah
i mean it's still the thing that i care
about the most you know and and i
i loved i think that there was a lot of
important messages in here especially
now you know everything is you know i
call them the e-bikes
um i have like it's like the the dawning
like the just the
how much you know like i talk about this
actually
back in the day when you said something
was nice someone just said that looks
nice thank you so much and that was it
now they go where they bought it how
much it costs where's it on sale
like everyone's a walking commercial you
would think that maybe everything is
embedded with some kind of subliminal
messaging
we decide everything from what clothes
are in style to when slang is involved
like it's just about product placement
everywhere it was so clear back in the
then and
very conspicuous and why are we doing
this and no one wanted to be a part of
it and now it's
it's just beyond the norm you know i was
watching people in concerts literally
like spelling out the letters to the
different you know
soda you know uh you know things that
we're trying to promote and like give me
a p give me an e give me a p you know
you're like
this is just it was we were really ahead
of our time in a lot of the messaging i
think that was in this and i think
that's one of the reasons why this is
this this film really holds because
there are some really important themes
that have
needed very much time oh right
we were totally ahead of our time we
didn't have social media then
and and our movie was almost out
too early you know then
what it would have been now because now
everyone understands it
the millenniums you know like but
no one i think at first got it and then
after time they did and i can't tell you
i'm sure rachel and rosario will take
the same thing
how many people come up to me and say
champions are life that's crazy
right have you guys gotten that i did an
interview the other day
with siriusxm about this and
the uh the person doing the interview
said that he had spoken to a lot of
bands who said
i actually realized that i could start a
band because of josie and the pussycats
good news bad news you you don't even
have to you can just pretend to start a
fan
i try to buy the right sorry you said
there's bad news
but wait terry you tried to buy the
rights for josie and the pussycats
yeah i did and the guy that owned it was
uh not so friendly
and because the movie like i'm tara reid
in the theaters
so he was like no like and i wanted us
to do it
like we're still not we still look young
you know and like i thought
man if we could do one more of josie the
pussycats and
you know rosario could rock out rachel
could rock out we could
i think it'd be really fun but obviously
we got we got turned down there
guys i try it hey rachel let me ask you
this one because you
um you know you mentioned before you
kind of talked about a tribe
what did this opportunity like doing a
movie like this teach you about like
what a good girl group means to your
life
and like you know having that kind of
support from a good a good tribe
well i mean generally of course it's the
most important thing i
i think most important things like in my
life and i hope every young girl's
life's to have great girlfriends but
just to speak you know personally um
i was at a point in my life when we made
this movie where i was just sort of
bouncing from
job to job and i would sort of be
usually dating someone and i would make
friends with his friends but then when
he left i would sort of be left to my
own devices and i didn't really
have a lot of close girlfriends at that
time and um
tara and rosario were i'm not gonna get
emotional
but they were right they were really
really there for me and um
i was kind of lonely before i met them
they meant a lot to me
i love you rachel i really love you both
so much
it really was like such a really
remarkable remarkable remarkable
experience and i'm really glad that
social media and all that stuff wasn't
going on around then because we really
this was an experience where people
weren't on their phones and disappeared
like people talked to each other
engaged like the whole crew we really
we created a real vibe that was just
really loving
and supportive and caring but your mom
made a
huge difference on that set
your mom hated the movie rachel and
rosario though have your kids
seen this have you guys got to introduce
them to this movie
i can't see my father's watched it yet
does she watch your other movies how
does she feel about like she doesn't
watch stuff
with me she'll come back and say
she's like so i watched rent i'm like
when did you watch brent i wanted to
watch that with you you know she just
does these things so i don't know
she this is her jam she loves music
she loves girlfriends and like girl
power
like he loves dress up she loves like
all of it like this is so her jam so i
really wouldn't be surprised because she
also she loves cats she loves
animals she loves the whole thing this
is her world
this is cool actually it would be fun to
sit down and watch it with our kids
your kids haven't seen it either someone
told my
kids that i'm awesome because like they
have not
like they're like creepiness i'm like
don't make that face
like
i love you i love you too joe's
and i love you belle and i love you mel
ladies thank y'all so much thank you so
much
i really do appreciate the time this was
so much fun i hope you all got out
as much out of it as i did because this
was a good time it was great
thank you love you i love you
[Music]